hello everyone my name is connor and i'm
delighted to welcome you for
madawi al-rashid and jeremy bone on
reform and
repression in saudi arabia now we'll be
getting underway in just a moment
before we do i'm going to run you
through the functionality of today's
site for anyone joining us for the first
time
or anyone who needs a quick refresher
now there's two main ways you can get
involved in tonight's event
the first is of course by asking a
question to ask your questions
simply click the q a top type in what
you want to say and hit send
now remember if you want your name to be
read out in the in the event and
subsequently in the podcast
do include your name with the question
before you hit the send button
the other main way to get involved is of
course on social media if you'd like to
tweet along with tonight's event please
use the hashtag
iq2 we're also on instagram our handle
is
at intelligentsquared the other thing to
note is of course before i hand you over
to our speakers is the book
if you do enjoy tonight's event and
you'd like to dig a bit deeper into
mcdowell
excellent book the sun king reform and
repression in saudi arabia
please do click the link in the chat top
it should be coming up now
you can go through to primrose hill who
is the intelligence square bookseller
get this very special discount to read
through the book yourself or even get
your christmas presents in early i'm
sure make a fantastic read
now it's time for me to hand you over to
our chair for this evening's event
he is the middle east editor of the bbc
he'll be well known to many of you
former lee of the armand in the middle
of east
on radio 4 as well as a correspondent in
jerusalem
and prior to becoming middle east editor
please give a warm virtual
welcome to jeremy bone
thank you very much uh it's great to be
here i've really been looking forward to
this session because there's actually
there's a
a lot to talk about and we have the best
person
possible to talk about
saudi arabia madawi al-rasheed she is
one of the foremost authorities on the
country
visiting professor professor of social
anthropology at the lse middle east
center
she's written a number of excellent
books
about saudi arabia one about the legacy
of king salman of course the current
king but now we have this one
here it is i'll wave it again in case
you didn't catch it when conor
waved it uh the sudden king reform and
repression in saudi arabia published by
hearst
as you can see from my notes in it my
post-it note sim
i have read this very thoroughly and
learnt a lot
enjoyed it and um
and you know for a foreign journalist
like myself saudi arabia to be honest
with you has always been a bit of a hard
nut to crack
first of all it's quite hard to work
there um
second of all a lot of what passes for
seemingly well informed comment i've
learned over the years
is quite often based on a bit of gossip
and speculation now
um one person who wrote with a great
deal of authority of course
was the late jamal khashoggi now his
appalling murder
broke the spell that had been painfully
woven
painstakingly woven i should say around
prince mohammed bin salman the crown
prince of saudi arabia known for short
of course as
mbs we're going to get on i'm sure to
that notorious killing and the effect of
it but
let's um madawi uh first of all let's
start
with begin at the beginning i mean did
people see him coming
thank you jeremy and thank you
intelligence square for this session
um um it wasn't um
inevitable that muhammad will rise to
become the crown prince in such a
short time given his age and his lack of
experience
but i think to understand why he came to
power
we have to look at the arab uprising in
2011 when quite a lot of dictators
looked as if they're on their way out
and
saudi arabia did have some kind of
agitations
uh demonstrations and the tide was
inevitably going to reach saudi arabia
because the demands of the
demonstrators in cairo in bahrain
in north africa and yemen were exactly
the same
in saudi arabia but i think
at that moment a decision was taken
and to promote a young prince who would
uh start social liberalization
open up saudi arabia socially and
economically
but keeping the political system intact
as it is as an absolute monarchy
so the choice was so obvious at the time
that king salman when he became king in
2015
he started promoting his one of his
youngest
sons and he was seen as the new face of
saudi arabia
a so-called modern creative
entrepreneurial and connected to the
rest of the world through
pop culture entertainment and also
global capital and investment so
mohammed bin salman was promoted
in order to mitigate against the tide of
the arab uprisings reaching saudi arabia
is one of the features is it not in the
in the the entire region
is that there's a very young population
a young population that suffers from a
lot of unemployment
so the the the the idea then was to
connect with these people is that
correct
yes absolutely but age is a construct
really
um and that's what i keep saying yeah it
is absolute
construct and we give it meaning
so i remember western journalists
talking about
the aging saudi monarchs one dying
followed and succeeded by another one
equally old and on the on the way
out and uh so the the
when the prediction was actually
rife that we will have a young western
educated
prince to become the future king of
saudi arabia but of course that didn't
happen
in both situations we do have a young
prince
but he wasn't western educated and so
people assume
that there is value to being young
or valued to being western educated
and therefore without understanding the
the politics of the saudi royal family
it is impossible to understand why
mohammed bin salman known as mbs
became so important and amassed so much
powers
in such a short time well the politics
of that family are rather complicated
and they have been
the dom well among the dominant forces
since the
18th century of course in in saudi
arabia and
the dominant force since well for
most of the last hundred years i suppose
um
just trying could you give us for those
of us um i would include myself in that
of course you sometimes get a bit
confused
by the tangled family trees and
uh the web of power the varying and
ebbing and flowing web of power
in saudi arabia could you sum up for us
what it is we really need to know
about saudi politics that produced this
you know remarkable man yes well there
are two
phases to understand the royal family or
royal politics
after the founder of the kingdom king
abdel aziz ibn saud died in 1952
he wanted the succession to
stay within his own sons which means
that
if a king dies it is his son who be his
brother sorry
who becomes king and this is unlike what
europe had experienced in its
various uh monarchies so the succession
went from
one son of the founder to his brother
horizontally a horizontal succession
and he had quite a lot of songs i mean
estimated to be around 45 but we get to
the 1990s
and after that the royal family was
running
out of eligible young
brothers of the king and king abdullah
saw the death of two uh members of the
royal family very senior one his crown
prince
and minister of defense who was the
deputy crown prince
king and at that point it became clear
that when salman becomes king
there won't be any brothers to succeed
him or eligible brothers they were old
existing ones or sidelined
so it was time to think about how the
succession could move from the
horizontal line to the vertical line
so king salman sacked his um
mohammed binayev who was the minister of
interior and the crown prince
and promoted his own son as crown prince
but he is yet to appoint a deputy crown
prince which is their tradition in saudi
arabia
and possibly because muhammad bin salman
is young
the king doesn't feel uh that
there will be a power vacuum should
something happens to him and he
is probably unlikely to to to die
and you know as as the previous crown
princes
did now
he has been making right from the outset
a lot of waves he really hit the ground
running
showing you know tremendous energy there
was the war
not necessarily constructive energy
there was the war in yemen
that's certainly when i first became
aware of this this man and his name when
all that started
um and then everything that's happened
ever since of course and there was that
november 2017 the extraordinary affair
in the ritz carlton
uh in riyadh where he he walled up
a couple of hundred prominent officials
and members of the
the royal family and uh essentially they
had to buy their way out of that
what was the real story behind that what
is the
um what was his motivation was he making
a point was he trying to show who's boss
or was it about knocking corruption
and trying to recoup money that some of
the notoriously corrupt
people in that country had uh stolen
well it's absolutely
not about corruption the problem that
muhammad bin salman because of his young
age and because of excluding
not only his own elder brother but his
other cousins who are more eligible
and who had experience in government
like muhammad binayev
he wanted to prove himself and prove
that he is tough
so he became minister of defense crown
prince
head of the economic council and
given the old age of his father he was
actually
running the show but this doesn't mean
that he had the consensus of the saudi
royal family behind him
and before king salman the
state was run like a multiple
fiefdoms and each senior prince has his
own ministry
so prince naive the crown prince had the
ministry of interior prince sultan had
the ministry of defense
and these are the main ministries and
they were almost like autonomous but
they came together
and they did not challenge their brother
however when mohammed bin salman was
promoted in 2017
there was no consensus of the royal
family
and a lot of members of that family
thought that
why mohammed bin salman when there are
eligible
princes who had more experience than him
so he
is living in fear for his life
and he is worried about coups by members
of the royal family
and as such he managed to uh
to have almost all the king the sons of
king abdullah
mithrib and the others and in the ritz
carlton
confiscated their assets because he was
worried about
him his his future
in a family that has not given him the
full support
and the consensus so by promoting
muhammad bin salman
the king king salman has sidelined so
many other princes
and corruption is a good cause and
so we see i mean the reason why i
argue in the book that it is this is not
about corruption it's because it was
selective
and it was selective in the sense that
he cherry-picked some princes who
might pose a threat and put them
in in the ritz carlton and the the
detention campaign against members of
his own family continued i mean the last
uh we heard about such a detection was
just like uh seven eight months ago and
he will continue to do
this in the future simply because um
he doesn't have that consensus that is
so important to
to have the family behind you and at the
moment they're all
gone silent for the moment do you think
that might last there is uh
it's not unknown for saudi king to be
removed from power
in the past uh do you think that um he
might
uh one day just simply run out of his
nine lives
well historically there has been cases
of saudi
kings removed from power the last one i
don't want to go into the 19th century
and what happened then
but in in the 1960s uh king saud was
deposed
forced to leave the country and he died
abroad and because faisal his
grandparents
challenged him and kicked him out
and then in 1975 king faisal himself was
assassinated
by his nephew in the palace so it is not
unlikely or unimaginable that we'll have
this kind of situation
especially after king salman dies as
king salman at the moment gives him a
legitimacy umbrella he's like the
untouchable now because he's
the the bright or so-called reformer
of the sun king but after salman dies
who knows there was an interesting story
in the guardian the other day about
the former crown prince mohammed bin
nayef who's been
well no one's quite sure but he appears
to be under house arrest
and has been for months on end and for
those who didn't see the story it was
essentially saying that there was a plot
on social media accusing him his lawyers
said this
accusing him of uh plotting a coup
perhaps an alliance with joe biden
and don't forget of course that nbs is a
is being a big friend of
of president trump and also the first
son-in-law jared kushner
and uh so the quote was that interested
me was it said that
this the social media activity was
coming from inside saudi arabia and
quote
40 of the tweets apparently show
bot-like behavior
now mbs himself and his allies have
quite adeptly used social media haven't
they to push their
their points do you think that is a
continuation of it
of that of that tendency yes when um
mohammad bin nayef was
detained almost like 10 months ago and
there were
uh rumors on twitter also by bots and
you know
uh the infamous twitter farm
outside riyadh and that he was on drugs
and then now they think that uh with the
change in the american administration
maybe muhammad bin naif will be revived
and brought
back simply because mohammed bin laden
was the choice of many western
government including britain because
of his work as uh in the war on terror
and he cooperated and provided
information
shared uh information on terrorism with
western intelligence services
so it in actually before he was deposed
only a week before he was deposed he was
given one of the
most prestigious cia
medals for his uh contribution to the
war on terror but then suddenly mohammed
bin salman
became the face of saudi arabia and
muhammad bin nayef sunk into oblivion
so i'm not surprised that these tweets
are
are circulating at the moment but
muhammad binay for muhammad bin salman i
mean they both
have a record of repression mohammed bin
naif was
so hated by many people in saudi arabia
because he
actually started the in the police state
and consolidated the surveillance and
the technology
that makes every saudi citizen very very
vulnerable
and it is ironic that
the the work that muhammad binayev had
done
has benefited his successor which is
mohammed bin salman
and he wasn't able to to actually
benefit from all that spying and
surveillance that he
he put in place we can't talk about
saudi arabia without talking about
religion
and we can't talk about religion in
saudi arabia
without talking about the very longs
there is a dog who's just trying to
climb up on here but
thank you pardon he's trying to lick me
um we cannot talk about
uh religion in saudi arabia without
talking about the
wahhabi version of islam and the
alliance
between the al saud family and that
particular
tendency in religion that goes back
until the middle of the
18th century is there a sense now though
that that
mohammed bin salman is is trying to do
things a bit differently
that he is not trying to be as reliant
on that alliance
with the wahhabi rubber stamp as his
predecessors might have been
yes but as you mentioned the wahhabi
tradition was instrumental in
in the foundation of the state but
mohammed bin salman wants to reverse
that
he is yet to succeed simply because he
still needs the wahhabis
so to just give you examples and he told
the guardian
to mention his interview when he said
that he wants to
start a moderate islam in saudi arabia
and moderate islam involves sort of
curbing the powers of the religious
scholars
surveying greater surveillance of
mosques etc
and also suppressing the islamists of
all
shades and colors um but
when he needs the wahhabis
he draws on their help to just give you
an example
in the war on yemen which started in
2015 um king salman
and mohammed bin salman relied on the
wahhabi clerics
to go to the battleground and and
encourage the soldiers to launch this
war because they called it jihad against
the infidels
and the infidels in this particular case
were the yemeni zadies who belonged to a
different branch of islam
that the wahhabis hate and detest and
think that they are not real muslims
so that that sort of sectarian discourse
which is
uh integrated in wahhabi doctrine
is promoted in the context of the war on
yemen
if for example saudis want to take any
civil resistance if they want to
demonstrate or express
an opinion or go on strike then the the
the king
and his son will use the wahhabi fatwas
which are religious decrees to prohibit
demonstrations because they can argue
that
it is against islam and you are
committing
blasphemy against god if you demonstrate
and therefore at the moment the wahhabi
tradition is
dormant but it can be reactivated on
demand
when king salman or his son mohammed bin
salman
want to use it it's out there they can
quickly sort of ignite its zeal
and and excesses and that's an alliance
which has
worked for them for 200 and well more
than 250 years
absolutely but at the moment mohammed
bin salman
probably thinks that they've exhausted
the islamic legitimacy of the regime
because
remember that the saudi kings are
the custodians of the two holy mosques
and therefore they claim that they are
leaders of the sunni muslim world or of
muslims in general
but that had been exhausted and reached
a dead end with the
9 11 event and since then
we see the promotion of nationalism as
an
alternative to religious nationalism so
mohammed bin salman adopted the slogans
ironically that
trump had promoted saudi arabia is great
or makes saudi arabia great
or saudi arabia is for saudis and all
these kind of slogans
are trying to create a new national
consciousness
to to promote people to push them to to
mobilize them but this nationalism is
centered on
loyalty to the to muhammad bin salman
and it's not really a loyalty to the
nation
it's loyalty to the future king and also
it has its own contradictions and
problems like all nationalisms in the
world
uh you just mentioned of course
president trump in his
um you know final hours more or less or
days
so most people think anyway in the white
house
uh what is your analysis
of the the changes that have happened in
the gulf in the last
few months with the normalization
agreements with the
uh between the emiratis and israel
bahrain as well
sudanese having their arms somewhat
twisted
to uh to join the party um
where exactly is saudi arabia
on that there was that meeting quite
recently between netanyahu
and mbs and uh you know one of the
the analysis that one reads quite a bit
is simply that
while king salman is still there he
can't give up the
the arab the saudi authored arab peace
plan which is of course that
um normalization with israel is fine as
long as it follows independence for the
palestinians
but once the old man's gone well who
knows yes
well at the moment i think it's the
king's dilemma king salman is damned if
he does
damned if he doesn't uh so he can't
he he has to go through a cost-benefit
analysis and see what he's getting out
of of this
and in a way you know trump was his
friend and the fra
uh jared kushner was a friend of
muhammad bin salman and they all worked
together
but saudi israeli relations date back to
the 1960s
and the saudis are actually the saudi
leadership
just can't go public with these
relations
and they can't go along the
the path of the united arab emirates or
bahrain or even sudan
simply because they worry about their
opinion of the of the people and they
would lose
actually the last sort of brick in their
sort of
legitimacy narrative
they can't rule without this sort of
you know claim that they uh
work on behalf of muslims given that
they
are the custodians of mecca and medina
but
king salman decided to wait
and see and it's interesting that
only this week and the there was
a news that netanyahu came to saudi
arabia for a very quick meeting
with muhammad bin salman and obviously
they denied it
although the news came in the israeli
press
but immediately within like a week
prince turki al-faisal who was
ambassador in london
and also the ex-director of the
intelligence services went to a
conference in bahrain
double iws and he sort of had this die
tribe about israel and he was actually
talking to his domestic audience
not to the people in the conference he
wanted to reassure them on behalf of the
king and his son that
saudi arabia is committed to the rights
of palestinians but the economic
intelligence and military cooperation
between the two countries saudi arabia
and israel had had
developed and there's a whole sort of
um literature on on the these
clandestine
relations we are
nearly running out of time on our 30
minutes before we open this up
order questions but a couple more things
so
first off how important in all this is
the shared
antipathy that the israelis and the
saudis have to iran
this is the common cause and the
worrying thing
is that they are both not restrained
and they may sort of launch a certain
attack
that would bring the whole region in
into war
um i think mohammed bin salman has
uh overestimated his military
capabilities
uh despite i mean in a country like
yemen
the war is five years old in yemen and
until now uh recently the houthi
missiles reached saudi territory
and they are intercepted sometimes they
hit a wrong target
and we have seen how the uh the oil
fields are
also attacked uh regularly throughout
these five years
one attack was so serious that it
stopped the
oil production and export so
in order they are both netanyahu and
uh mohammed bin salman might be foolish
to launch an attack that would bring the
whole region
into more war and devastation
let's talk a little bit about the um
the loving that happened in the early
years
of uh mohammed bin salman's tenure as
as crown prince there was that uh
celebrated trip to the united states the
gushing pieces about this great bearer
of a man who might be
who might be king of saudi arabia into
the next century
etc etc etc then of course
things changed greatly after the uh the
murder of hashoji in the
consulate in istanbul uh the
celebrated american columnist tom
friedman i think gave him a very very
uh favorable reception when he burst
onto the scene when mbs did
um what do you make of that whole
the whole mechanism the loving then
followed by the
uh the sort of the realization when the
curtain was drawn back
on that terrible killing and what does
that say to you as well about
western observers and would-be
interpreters
of what's what's going on yes i think
thomas friedman and many others in
respectable
uh us and uk uh uh media
uh fell under the spell of mohammed bin
salman
it was almost like wishful thinking that
he would be this imposing
young man very energetic who works until
like
3 a.m in the morning and plays video
games
i mean there was this sensational sort
of reporting on saudi arabia
and i think um it it goes back
earlier than journalism it goes back to
how many
uh travelers and western writers
glorified ibn saud the founder of the
kingdom
although he was in alliance with the
most radical
religious groups that had emerged in the
arab world for centuries but i do
remember writing
reading british travelers glorifying
this man who came from the desert
there is that kind of it was the size
too they like didn't they
just like with mbs he was a tall man
imposing not like those other little men
i suppose they meant
yes so unfortunately western media fell
under the spell and thought that you
know reform in saudi arabia is all about
allowing women to drive going to theater
watching football matches inviting pop
stars to the country
having boxing matches where women could
actually attend
but none of those western journalists
asked the big
question the taboo question is there any
sign of political reform uh is there a
sign of having a representative
government in saudi arabia
there were no signs of any kind of
elections
and that might take place and give the
people a voice
and only when jamal khashoggi was
murdered on the 2nd of october 2018
that you know thomas friedman and the
others thought that oh
we got it wrong it is time now to
reconsider
our assessment this is a brutal murder
of
one of us and jamal khashoggi was a
journalist
you mentioned changes to those
restrictions on
on women you know the most celebrated of
course
the prohibition on driving and i
have there not been a few reforms the
guardianship
system but do you think that despite the
fact that of course
at the same time as he was allowing some
more freedoms he was putting
female protesters feminists in jail do
you think that
uh muhammad bin salman has made life
better in any sense for women in saudi
arabia
some women are enjoying the right to
drive
and and this professional women who have
to go to their jobs teachers
nurses doctors etc but this
comes a very very high price and the
restriction on freedom of expression a
restriction
on women's ability to represent
themselves are still
in place until the present day a saudi
woman cannot marry
without the authorization or the
permission
of her guardian so in marriage women
are not regarded as adults and they need
to be represented
and they have to seek permission to get
married
so yes there are certain changes that
had affected women in a positive
way but i think you can't talk about
this kind of social liberalization
without real rights
without real political right without the
idea of equal citizenship
and we are still far behind other
countries in the region
let alone in in the world and so yes
there is reform but there
is heavy-handed repression at the same
time legend
who is a feminist young 30 year old
activist who campaigned for the right to
drive and got arrested and put in prison
in 2014
but she's still in prison now and when
mohammed bin salman came to power
she was summoned to prison and she is
now transferred to a court that deals
with terrorism
and she is just an educated woman who
campaign but it is not surprising that
mohammed bin salman picked
those women and put them in prison
because the feminist movement in saudi
arabia had surpassed
all schisms within society whether they
are regional
ideological or even
sectarian so women's right you united
so many regions so many tribal groups
and this is why mohammed bin salman
feared this
rising vocal feminist movement
and he prefers regions and groups to
work within their own sect within their
own
community but a national opposition
is what he actually fears
right we have got um variety of
questions coming in as a matter of fact
so let's uh start dealing with a couple
of those
um can you this is from ananda
could you talk a little bit about mbs
and his relationship with the united
arab
emirates who is the senior partner and
how will the election of joe biden
change this
yeah and it is a very very um opaque
relationship but i think mohammed bin
salman's season this is this is the
relationship with mbz
the yes and the ruler the effective
ruler of that of that country
um he is impressed by dubai
rather than the whole of the uae and he
thought that he could turn saudi arabia
into another
uae on a much bigger scale
and his relation obviously like all
these kind of
personalized political relations it's
very difficult to know what goes on
but it is obvious that uh the uae
early on wanted to play a role bigger
than its
size and even its wealth and
they saw the threat of uh islamism
in the region as undermining their
success
story or the so-called success story of
dubai
and i think the decision was reached in
the u in abu dhabi
the capital that in order to defeat
islamism you really need to defeat it
in its own country of origin and that is
saudi arabia
so mbz is very keen on
silencing all islamist voices and
becoming the policeman of the gulf um
and he he has uh uh played
sort of the guiding uh uh
elder to mohammed bin salman uh
so far but we shall see like all these
kind of personalized relations
they are not based on some kind of solid
institutional
connections and they come and go
depending on personalities in in power
um and uh and i'll ask say a follow-up
did the uae player a role
in the appointment of mbs there was
apparently an article in the new york
times which i
clearly missed suggesting there was a
very strong link on that
uh it i mean mbz
uh through his ambassador in washington
he
built uh uh many connections and
he reminds me of his ambassador reminds
me of bender bun sultan if you remember
jeremy in the 1990s and then
before and even up to 9 11.
so he had these personalized relations
with the bush family with the oil
corporations and i think after the
departure of muhammad
of bender bin sultan the saudi
ambassador
and the uae wanted to fill that vacuum
and play the role and sort of be the the
sounding board
of the american administration and it
coincided with trump
uh coming to power who was very much
interested
in the transactional foreign policy
that you know if you buy my arms or arms
from my country
i'm happy to support you and and that
went on and mohammed bin
salman benefited from that kind of
context
um on the subject of arms is a question
from me
actually um do you think the
uh well we hear a lot in this country
but the british and the americans
clearly we sell vast amounts of uh
weaponry sophisticated weaponry to saudi
arabia
and there is that intelligence
relationship and if you talk to
um members of the conservative
government here for example about our
relations with saudi arabia
they'll say well yes that we have put
pressure on them on some issues because
we're not that happy with some of the
things they've been doing like bombing
civilians in yemen
with planes we sold them and maintained
um
but you know the relationship is very
important economically
and as well as that it's deeply rooted
in our common history we go back a long
way
and uh and as well as that of course
there's that intelligence relationship
and
believe you me is what they say the
saudis have helped us
no end in dealing with extremism in our
own country
well i mean this is the uh the discourse
of
successive british governments um and
also
in the united states uh but it i think
the in terms of cost benefit
and there had been a lot of studies on
british
relations with saudi arabia and the arms
sales
and it is actually blown out of
proportion
yes there are jobs but they're not the
only jobs in the country
and britain could have a a foreign
policy
with a country like saudi arabia and
upholding
its values and it doesn't mean that you
sell them these planes
that are used to bomb yemen you you make
that relationship
conditional on these uh regimes and
these dictatorships respecting
the basic rights of their citizens and
their neighbors
but um i think britain likes the idea
of having this so yet another special
relationship with saudi arabia because
it makes it
project its power abroad it makes it
feel better
that they have this really special
inverted commas with the saudis
but i mean since the second world war
this had been the dilemma of britain
as the united states displaced britain
in terms of
having the special relationship with
with saudi arabia
and and the british logic is that if we
don't sell
sell saudi arabia arms then the french
would
and this is the kind of uh
weapons market that is global uh
backed by powerful governments and
and they're all searching for new
opportunities and markets
unfortunately and you know without a
vigorous
um control over arms sales and
we we are going to continue pumping
these regimes with weapons
that are used either against their own
people or against their neighbors
and you accelerate the chances of a
war as we have seen the yemen war was
the first war that the saudis
used to to test their military
capabilities
they've never fought a war on on their
own their
has never fought a war on its own since
the creation of the state
the gulf war in 1990 was fought with 500
000 foreign soldiers mainly americans
and therefore
and they wanted to test their military
capabilities and
and and started a war in yemen that that
precipitated the humanitarian crisis
that is still ongoing uh let's talk a
little bit about the
the the murder of jamal hashoji
um some men have been put on trial
uh what is likely to happen to them um
mbs himself has denied that he had
anything to do with it though i think
trump isn't
trump said to woodward that uh i saved
that guy's ass
on this particular subject um
so if they took the orders
of the crown prince if of course i can't
prove it but
all the circumstantial evidence seems to
suggest that
the question is will they take the fall
for him
uh will how does it work will their
families have been
given money to buy their silence will
they be discreetly ushered out of jail
in a year or two
yes well it's an opaque judiciary in
saudi arabia
and we don't know much about
the process the procedure and
they needed to have scapegoats to
silence their loud voices around the
world
uh that condemned this this uh crime
and the the magnitude of the crime
makes one believe uh with certainty that
it could not have happened without
some serious orders from
above and and the details of it at the
time were horrific and i documented in
the book because i relied on
on the accounts of the woman who was
with khashoggi just standing outside
his fiancee and the saudis would not
allow an independent uh investigation
they refused from day one and they
regarded that
as an infringement on their sovereignty
but
sovereignty or no sovereignty you commit
a crime abroad
on the premises of your consulate i
think the regime has gone
too far in that particular well
that does appear yeah that very much
does appear to be the consensus though
of course
um western countries certainly seem
quite prepared to
forgive and forget as soon as they they
can um
an interesting question here from the
audience uh do you think that saudi
arabia could ever be
a democracy what would need to happen
well it can be a democracy there's
nothing that stops a country from being
a democracy
you need two conditions you need the
people to mobilize for democracy
inside the country and you need an
international context that doesn't
block the development of democracy like
what happened in
in egypt for example in 2011 when
people did demonstrate and did uh
pay a high price but then there were
counter-revolutionary forces in the
region
assisted by some western governments
that
derailed that drive towards democracy
and saudi arabia is not
an exceptional case there are people
calling for democracy
we do have now a diaspora that
consists of young men and women
who had left the reforms and the
the paradise of mohammed bin salman and
they're stranded in
around the globe from canada to the
united states britain
australia europe and any and other
countries
and one thing that actually encouraged
me to write this book
is to ask a question if mohammed bin
salman is such a great reformer
why are those saudis leaving the country
and becoming exiles and asylum seekers
abroad
women if he's promoting and empowering
women
why have we got runaway girls and this
is a new phenomena
runaway girls young girls who leave the
country without the permission of their
guardians
they escape and once they arrive in
international airports around the world
they seek asylum
so if if driving is the dream of every
saudi woman why do these young women
leave the country when driving becomes
uh
legal so it's it's a very very mixed uh
um situation um and democracy
is not uh beyond the the
horizon of many saudis they can
participate
in nor in elections they understand the
principles of democracy
um now your family and you yourself of
course have been outside saudi arabia
quite a long time long you know much
perceiving
um mohammed bin salman tell us what your
family's story was
it's a long story but uh we've got about
we've got about five minutes are gone
right
uh well i mean it it's you're i'm born
into a family that had a history
in in the country as local rulers of
part of what is now saudi arabia
and they had battles uh and they lost uh
the war to the
uh to the al saud but also they
they uh are interconnected through a
series of marriages
uh with the al saud because they're part
of this arabian sort of nobility
and and in my situation i sort of became
an exile as a teenager i didn't choose
to be an exile it's because of
the position of my father my uncle
and and the whole family history
so i left in saudi arabia 75 then
returned
briefly and then at the end i came to
britain to study
and decided to stay and i i
i chose a career that can never flourish
in a dictatorship you cannot write
history or social science in a country
like saudi arabia if you
if you want to maintain your ability to
have critical thinking and it is
impossible
all my books are banned in saudi arabia
in fact amnesty international reported
that one of the charges against a group
of civil
society activists and when they went to
court in
saudi arabia that they had my books and
articles stored on their computer
so if a history book or definitely the
sun king
will not be allowed in saudi arabia it
will be censored
but if you can't write with freedom if
you can't
defend human rights if you can't
engage in conversation with feminists
islamists
nationalists and if you can't do all
these things you can't really become an
academic in saudi arabia unless you
become a loyalist
academic and i chose not not to go down
that path because
i i couldn't be a loyalist in a regime
that deprives me of my basic freedom of
speech
now this excellent book and i um
here we are show you the cover again um
is
full of really
very forensic criticisms of
the sun king the title itself uh
of uh mohammed bin salman do you ever
feel in danger
yourself you've been every bit as
critical as
uh hashoji was yes i mean i've been in
danger a long time ago
when i published my phd thesis
in 1991 and i i received
threats that if if i was going to
publish it i will be subjected to
disciplinary action
and that came from the saudi government
before mbs
but after khashoggi was murdered
all saudi exiles and there was a growing
community
in london and in washington everywhere
and
we became very very um um
troubled by how far the regime could
go to eliminate uh critical voices
but if if i'm gonna live in fear
i should go back to saudi arabia i
cannot live abroad
in fear because of my writing or what my
writing would call
and once you make that decision then
you know you dismiss this moment of
fear and i i do believe
that i'm only writing words um and
obviously words are not appreciated in
dictatorships so
um i will continue my academic career
my writing and i i
deliberately take the side of the people
the who are
in saudi prisons and of the women who
are
detained simply for asking for certain
rights that the whole popul the whole
world
enjoys and once you make that decision i
think you
you become um a target
um and you won't be accepting any
invitations to
conferences in saudi arabia with a
private jet to take you there
well absolutely not i wouldn't even go
to the saudi embassy in london or the
consulate i do remember as a student in
britain my saudi passport expired
and i would not go to the embassy or the
consulate to renew my passport
because i knew and i had the awareness
that
governments can do nasty things in in
their consulates or
embassies because their sovereign
territories belonging to them
we are just well well quite right yeah
well there's proof isn't there so
um we are almost running out of time but
time for a couple of quick questions
oil as we try to use less oil
in the rest of the world what effect is
that going to have on saudi arabia whose
economy
is of course already getting squeezed
yes absolutely there is a shift and it
is
uh in world consumption even without
covert
uh and for a country that is totally
dependent
on oil mohammed bin salman
is trying to diversify but it doesn't
happen
overnight they had been used to uh oil
revenues
and uh part of his plan in vision 2030
is to to increase the diversification of
the economy
and we shall see uh it's he he has been
forced to draw on
um the national sovereign fund
uh to cover uh ex government expenditure
and also borrowing so that is going to
actually change the dynamics the
political dynamics be
between the ruling family and society
a society that has been used to a
welfare state that is well
developed housing education
scholarships abroad and all that is
going to stop
um we've got a few more questions i just
wanted to get on to
there was one that was asked some time
ago actually you know there have been so
there's been some talk that the custody
of the uh
the holy mosque in jerusalem might be
transferred to saudi arabia
at the moment formally it's of course in
the hands of jordan
do you see anything in that any bit i
doubt it
actually um very difficult
to do yeah yeah okay um
let's talk a little bit about uh the
jihadist extremists al-qaeda some extent
isis the question is
uh the saudi elite funded and supported
al-qaeda and to some extent isis
what would it take for us to see that
dynamic
re-emerging as i said earlier
um you know the wahhabi tradition is
still there
and it is used at the moment selectively
in the war um on yemen and
uh in sort of suppressing any kind
of political activism in the country
and as long as it's there you know it
can be reactivated
um if we look just briefly at the
history
the heavy movement emerged in the 18th
century and then the ottoman empire
destroyed it at the beginning of the
19th century
but it was still there and it was
revived by the el saud at the beginning
of the 20th century with the help of the
british government at the time
so it it goes in cycles and i wouldn't
be surprised if
it splinters into something else and
erupts in different
ways but you have to think of it as a
totalitarian system
and any totalitarian system is subject
to
being fractured and you have splinter
group
emerging because they argue about the
interpretation of their doctrines and
texts
all the time and the the jihadi
tradition
or the al-qaeda they used aspect of the
wahhabi tradition
interpreted in a different way so they
and the loyal wahabis only differ
slightly
about interpretation of their doctrine
because they have the same source
and and this we know like totalitarian
system
always break up and always have radical
fringe movements
and and i wouldn't be surprised if it
erupts again
in in some time in the future
uh tell us how significant saudi support
was for al-qaeda during its more
prominent days and of course
various affiliates very much still exist
and when i put these questions myself to
you know
important or unimportant people in saudi
arabia they say well look we worked very
hard to to
to stop these people we eliminated them
it's absolutely wrong
to say that uh the saudis
um expedited those particular
movements in different parts not just to
the middle east but elsewhere
where does the truth lie on that one
well it said there are historical
records that
many historians academics including
myself had consulted
and the the whole idea of this
uh global jihad you go to afghanistan
first and they thought that they could
it is the child
of many governments and not only the
saudi government
so saudi arabia provided the doctrine
and the money the united states britain
and other countries
pushed for that uh project and
pakistan facilitated it on the ground
so in order to defeat the soviet union
they thought radical
islam or islam at the time could be an
antidote to communism
and it can mobilize muslims around the
globe
to go to afghanistan and liberate it and
and that was the
the the the saudi government's
active participation you i don't know
many
how many people know that king salman
himself
was running a fund to help the jihadis
to go to afghanistan and also they
were given a reduction on saudi airline
to fly to peshawar and to other cities
in pakistan and regroup
with osama bin laden so that that
phase is forgotten as saudi arabia
switched from a supporter of that
afghan jihad to being a victim of of
that jihad
um so it was easier for them
to fall out with the saudi leadership
and turn against the saudi leadership
and the saudi leadership also
started feeling the pressure in between
20
2003 and 2008 saudi arabia witnessed the
worst
uh terrorism episode in its modern
history
because those afghan arabs as they were
called
returned to saudi arabia and started a
terrorism campaign
so they actually tasted what they have
been exporting
and it's it's it was a misguided policy
on behalf of several governments
to weaponize islam in the fight against
the soviet union
that weaponization we are still living
under the dark side of that
misguided foreign policy um
madawi we are we've finally run out of
time i'd like to thank you
very much for taking part in what for me
has been and
i'm sure for everybody else an
absolutely fascinating
hour i'd like to thank of course not
just you but the audience intelligence
squared
i'd also like to remind everybody
watching here that you can get
well not just one copy you can order
multiple copies
of the book with the intelligent square
discount and that is via the link
in the chat tab at the right hand side
of uh of your screen and uh
you know it's been really really
interesting and by the way
um guys there are lots of books around
at the moment about this particular man
forget this one start here the others
are good too but this is the one that
matters this is where you begin
so thank you so much once again for
uh talking to us this evening thank you
yes thank you jeremy and madawi and just
to reiterate what
uh was already said by jeremy thank you
all for your amazing questions i can
already see in the chat
top we have sean and kathy thanking uh
madawi and jeremy for their
contributions it was really
fascinating taking us right through from
the history of saudi arabia to
the future of the kingdom quick reminder
if you did enjoy the event the sun came
one more
show of the book yeah
do get the intelligent square discount
via the via the chat tab and reminder if
you did see jeremy's dog walk in
and you'd like to hear more about cats
vs dogs that's tomorrow's debate on
intelligence squared
so do tune in for that and and plenty
more coming up on intelligence squared
in the coming weeks
thanks again to madawi and jeremy and
have a lovely evening